Helmed by Damon Lindelof, HBO's Watchmen series
serves as a new and original story based within
the world created by Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons.
And the cast members assembled for the show
are top-notch.
From Academy Award winners to Coen Brothers
regulars, here's where you've probably seen
them before.
Watchmen features active police officers who
wear masks while on duty to defend against
the Seventh Kalvary, a violent group inspired
by the original comic book's character Rorschach.
Since members of the Kalvary wear masks that
mimic Rorschach's signature ink-blot look,
the police don masks as well, thanks to a
law that allows officers to hide their true
identities from those who might target them.
One of those officers is Detective Angela
Abar, played by Regina King, who masquerades
under the identity of Sister Night.
"I got a nose for white supremacy, and he
smells like bleach."
King has had a long and successful career
in Hollywood, which becomes clear when you
look at her slate of major awards.
She's nabbed three Emmys and a Golden Globe,
and then she took home an Academy Award for
her supporting turn in 2018's If Beale Street
Could Talk.
You might've also seen her in films like Boyz
n the Hood, in supporting TV roles on shows
like The Big Bang Theory, and as the star
of Netflix's short-lived Seven Seconds.
For a little while, Jeremy Irons' role in
Watchmen was kept quiet, lending an air of
mystery to the proceedings.
But ultimately an HBO featurette broke the
news about who he would be playing.
The behind-the-scenes look featured cast interviews
referring to Irons as Ozymandias, a.k.a. Adrian
Veidt, a hugely important character from the
original comic known as the "World's Smartest
Man."
"Would you like it to occur to me, sir?"
"There are so many things I'd like to occur
to you.
All right, dimwits.
On with the show!"
Irons is one of a select number of performers
who have won the Triple Crown of Acting: an
Emmy, a Tony, and an Oscar.
He's had an incredible career on the stage
and screen, and you've undoubtedly seen, or
heard, at least one of his acclaimed performances
over the years.
One of his most famous performances only features
his voice, but even so, his turn as the villainous
Scar in The Lion King is unforgettable.
Beyond the African plains, his notable roles
include Reversal of Fortune, for which he
won his Oscar, and Alfred Pennyworth in the
DCEU.
In a world that requires constant protection
for police officers under attack from roving
terrorist groups, the police chief has to
be a powerful presence, protecting his officers
from danger while still somehow trying to
keep the peace.
In this version of Watchmen, that job falls
to Don Johnson as Chief Judd Crawford.
Johnson has led an illustrious career, but
he might not be immediately recognizable to
younger viewers.
Despite a few high-profile recent supporting
turns in movies like Django Unchained and
Book Club, he's undoubtedly best known for
his time as Sonny Crockett on Miami Vice,
the hit NBC detective show that ran from 1984
to 1989.
These days, Johnson might be best known to
some people for his talented offspring, as
his daughter Dakota Johnson has made a name
for herself in movies like Fifty Shades of
Grey and Bad Times at the El Royale.
"I've had some ladies walk up to me and go,
'What do you think of your daughter in this
movie?'"
One of the new characters in this version
of Watchmen is known as Looking Glass, and
he's played by Tim Blake Nelson.
He's a super-sharp cop with excellent interrogation
skills who might have a more sinister personality
lurking under the surface.
In an interview on the Empire Podcast, Nelson
revealed,
"I don't really completely understand him,
and that's intentional.
Damon Lindelof metes out facts about your
character as you go along...so I'm learning
as I go along who this guy is, and trying
to...It's almost like fresco painting.
The clay is always wet."
"You know what strange means."
Luckily, Nelson is no stranger to complicated
characters.
Some of his most notable roles include his
collaborations with fraternal filmmaking duo
Joel and Ethan Coen.
He played one of the escaped convicts in O
Brother, Where Art Thou? and the titular singing
cowboy in The Ballad of Buster Scruggs.
He's also shown up on TV occasionally, including
memorable guest turns on the likes of Unbreakable
Kimmy Schmidt and Modern Family.
An ideal way to connect Moore's Watchmen universe
to HBO's version is to feature familiar characters
who have aged since audiences last checked
in with them.
So fans will likely be pleased to see Silk
Spectre once again.
As played by Jean Smart, she's now working
as an FBI agent and going by the name Laurie
Blake.
A formidable performer, Smart is the perfect
person for such an indispensable character.
From 1986 to 1991, she was best known for
her leading role on the popular CBS sitcom
Designing Women.
Since then, she's continued an incredible
career, including roles on Frasier as an old
classmate of Frasier's and on 24 as the First
Lady of the United States.
In 2015, she appeared in the second season
of FX's Fargo, for which she nabbed the eighth
Emmy nomination of her career.
Beyond the small screen, her film roles include
a small but crucial part in 2018's A Simple
Favor.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.